Hari:
You can't save yourselves.
But you can save your legacy.
♪♪
(Walking) (Water drips)
Demerzel:
You can't be here.
You know that.
I can't be the first one who
wanted to see my youngest self.
(Plinked)
♪♪
Strange.
Watching yourself being born.
♪♪
Brother Day:
Our genetic dynasty has reigned
for almost four-
centuries.
♪♪
Brother Day:
The might of the Imperium
(Explosions)
Brother Day:
has brought peace to thousands
of worlds.
♪♪
Brother Day:
But the beliefs of one man.
♪♪
Brother Day:
Now threaten the empire's very
existence.
♪♪
I'm not a revolutionary.
Gaal:
His calculations are correct.
The Empire is dying.
Hari:
Order will vanish.
Wars will be endless.
Only we can shorten the
darkness.
♪♪
Brother Day:
The man has amassed a following.
People who hinge their hopes on
every
word Seldon utters.
♪♪
Brother Day:
Words have a way of fanning
into wildfires.
♪♪
Hari:
You can't save yourselves.
♪♪
Hari:
But you can your legacy.
♪♪